à l'époque où tous les paparazzismes
courait derrière je pourrais pas faire
un pas où ils allaient ils prenait
d'aller louer les chambres de bonnes en
face pour me photographier chez moi au
moment de l'accouchement avec Nicolas
etc partout j'allais j'étais traquée
toujours tombé un clic de écouter
j'avais un sixième sens personne
d'entendait un clic d'appareil photo
sauf moi je disais il y a un type qui
vient de me prendre une photo et on se
rendait compte qu'il y avait un mec
planqué personne n'avait vu je lavais
ressenti c'est comme un les chasseurs
avec le gibier quoi ça ça je l'ai
ressenti ça
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
Mireille Dumas abonnez-vous et activez
la cloche
[Musique]